we want you to participate virtually in
the World Economic Forum's summer Davos
in China this sep tember the theme of
the meeting is driving growth through
sustainability at the annual meeting of
the new champions held in Tianjin we
want to know about your solutions for
sustainability how can we manage
resources more efficiently how can we
increase energy efficiency how can we
lower carbon emissions how can we
rebuild basic infrastructure these are
just a few questions that we want you to
help answer all innovative ideas are
welcome because driving growth through
sustainability is fundamental for global
national and business competitiveness in
the twenty-first century ready to pitch
upload your pitch using a visually
stimulating presentation that's no
longer than two minutes to youtube.com
slash Devils the more visual the better
don't forget to vote for your favourite
presentation to the best entry will be
shown to some of the most powerful and
influential people in the world
including presidents and business
leaders at our summer Davos in China go
to youtube.com slash davos to join the
conversation